vous parliez tout à l'heure de rentrer
si vous voulez oublier les soucis de
votre rentrée bien aller au cinéma
engouffré vous dans une salle et laissez
vous porter par un film événement qui
sort aujourd'hui qui a été coproduit par
fr3 qui est de jacques rivette et qui
s'appelle la belle noiseuse regardez un
extrait
ex
tout vrai à un pays nous allâmes taille
et le rideau
et cet extrait illustre bien le film
celle d'un face à face entre un jeune
modèle beaux modèles emmanuelle béart et
vous michel piccoli vous êtes le peintre
c'est un face à face rude choc violent
parce que en deux mots c'est l'histoire
d'un peintre les faits qui n'arrivent
plus à peindre qui avait qui vit le plus
grand bonheur avec sa femme jane birkin
qui était avant son modèle mais n'arrive
plus à parler qu'on lui force la main ne
fut un contrat et on lui présente une
nouvelle jeune femme qui pourrait être
son futur modèle et il accepte ce pari
de reprendre son travail avec ce nouveau
modèle
alors pourquoi la belle noiseuse
pourquoi ce titre c'est une appellation
un peu anciennes qui vous dira la bulle
cieux zabel emmerdeuse
mais à tous cela dit avec beaucoup
d'amour oui mais on a l'impression en
regardant ce film qu'au début du moins
le noise heures c'est vous sigean se
dire je peux se dit c'est l'emmerdeur
oui c'est moi l'emmerdait en effet mais
est ce que le marchand de tableaux qui
me fait passer le contrat n'est pas
belle en mer de barents
il va toucher a explosé un peu pervers
m'enfin le chef-d'oeuvre existera on le
verra jamais dans le film il veut être
suffisamment une pudeur pour ne pas
montrer le chef d'oeuvre du peintre
vous avez employé un mot étrange pudeur
oui et c'est un peu étrange parce que
tout au long du film via une femme nue
qui pose pour vous c'est donc emmanuelle
béart
c'est marianne et comment avez vous
réussi à concilier l'inconciliable
elle est nue on la voit nue dans toutes
les positions et vous dites pudeur dans
toutes les positions mais pas dans des
positions
scabreuses oui dans d'une manipulation
physique extravagantes mais d'abord
rivette tu es un homme qui a un grand
amour de la femme ce qui est plus en
plus rares jeunes cinéastes ou mabire et
c'est un homme extrêmement discret moi
je me suis comporté de la façon la plus
discrète possible
emmanuel a beaucoup souffert mais on l'a
beaucoup aidée et c'est une commune et
l'extraordinaire parce qu'on regarde
plus au visage bhuiyan obscénité j'ai
entendu toutes les questions que mes
confrères opposé à emmanuelle béart
l'homme en essais nous apprêter gêné
justement de tourner nue
moi je pose la question à l'homme et
vous ont pas été troublé je la voyais
tellement angoissé que je
elle a été capable de me passer
l'angoissent alors je les ai mis en
confiance en nous disant particulier que
si jamais elle croyait voix de moins un
regard qui ne correspondaient pas ce
qu'il fallait
ou un geste maladroit tout de suite
qu'elle me le dise que je ne m'encombre
de rien et je dois dire que chaque fois
que les prises se terminait jeu baisser
les yeux tourner la tête pour laisser le
spectateur lui ne va pas baisser les
yeux et va regarder ce film tout au long
de tout c'est celle de 700 t on de ce
face à face entre le peintre et la jeune
emmanuelle mais à partir d'un certain
moment on oublie tout et on attend le
tableau oui oui c'est un curieux chine
il joue quatre heures oui c'est un film
sur la création sur l'art sur la
peinture sur les rapports aussi amoureux
magnifiquement magnifié par yvette nous
mais c'est aussi un film à suspense est
très étrange quand le film terminé j'ai
été surpris à quel point pendant quatre
heures nous dit mais qu'est ce qui va se
passer qu'est ce qui va arriver
alors je rassure les téléspectateurs on
peut le regarder pendant quatre heures
ne s'en lasse pas mais vous ne craignez
pas que n'aille pas par crainte de
rester trop longtemps dans la salle on
ne sait pas où ça va on avait déjà
beaucoup de craintes comme ce film était
demandée par le festival de cannes c'est
d'y aller à cannes avec un film de
quatre heures et à +1 films de rivette
c'est dangereux et bien ça a été ne
soyons pas modestes
un triomphe est-ce que ça va continuer
le moins de public le public seul le
dira cela dit c'est un film qui est haut
rhin a publiquement sur les années
futures qui rassurera douloureux pour
les producteurs mais je pense qu'il s'y
retrouveront il a en tout cas obtenu le
grand prix spécial du jury à cannes
merci beaucoup monsieur été commis à
vous merci